oh
spicy hey everyone it's Esther Choi I'm
a chef and entrepreneur but my true
passion has always been spicy food I
feel like my spice tolerance is kind of
crazy I can take a lot of heat oh God
that was spicy
if you love the heat of hot ones then
join me and some of my friends as we hit
the streets for a fiery culinary
Adventure where I eat and learn about
the world's spiciest Cuisines
it's so good it seemed like flashes of
my ancestors right now from pallet
scorching Mexican Peppers habanero
cheers to sinus clearing Sichuan hot
pots I'm sorry I gotta pull my nose
ah
we'll be right back after this
commercial
you're jerking K-Town spicy challenges
my tears are spicy right now tongue
searing Thai Spice Thai spicy is like
someone slapping you across the face
inducing Caribbean Heat
first ever behind the scenes look at hot
ones
my mouth is starting to burn that's hot
you guys have water yeah that's spicy
you ready to sweat we're heat eater can
you take the heat because this is heat
eaters
[Music]